Please look up the sunk cost fallacy.
This is what you're falling into.
There are a ton of fucking fallacies.
And if you didn't learn this shit in English class,
your fucking high school teacher failed you.
These are just logical fucking fallacies.
Like it's logical mistakes that people make
in making decisions that cause us to stumble.
And they're so fucking common
there's a name for them. You feel like, oh,
I've invested so much time,
money, energy,
whatever the fuck, the resources that you feel is limited,
I've sunk all this into this thing,
so I have to keep going.
But that's exactly how those motherfuckers on the submarine ended up
where they ended up.
Because you don't have to keep going with something
just cause you put a bunch into it.
I admire the fucking women who have the nerve to like,
walk away on their wedding day.
Or literally like, I'm not,
I'm. I don't give a fuck how many deposits,
I don't give a. How many.
Fuck, how many people are disappointed,
I'm not going through with it,
I can't, I can't.
And they listen to themselves.
Because you're just saving yourself so much trouble in the end.
Because you know what? If you feel this way,
I guarantee you the relationship's gonna end.
And when it does, at that point,
the only thing you'll regret is, fuck,
why didn't I leave the first fucking time?
So I'm telling you with every ounce of passion,
In my body. Samantha,
Nana, you and every other one of you watching.
If you have that feeling, it's not gonna get any better.
This person is not gonna magically stop abusing you.
He's not gonna. Magic.
If he's over 25, his brain is fully developed.
If he's over thirty. Girl,
not only is his brain fully developed,
he's now an old dog set in his ways.
Ain't gonna teach him no new fucking tricks.
Save yourself.